Ages and what I like about him do
we stand for the same thing, Eh,
then I stand for, for against
the performance enhancing drug.
And I think is very important for me.
And it,
for me it was that cannot
honor to fighting him.
It was like a lot of guy he lost to this
guy that they would have been cut on
performance enhancing drugs
and, and um, he's very open.
He talks about it all the time
and then I think is great.
Great model for this part. Yeah, I know,
I agree. I agree. And a great model for,
it's just an example of how you can
achieve great things if you work hard.
And that's what he's done is
he's one of that guy that like,
I hate him when I wasn't trying again,
but I loved them as well. And the same,
same time.
I remember at one point I want to point
where in a conference in Toronto and
that is it. And the larger
story, I've thought a conference,
we go by the bag, kind of the
back door of a mall. And um,
there's like a, I don't know if it's
a, it was staged or not. I've, I mean,
I'm not aware if it was stage, I wasn't
that aware of it. So there's a camera,
like I think he's said was TMZ or
something. It was a camera that follow.
So there were kids following us
too. They're about to ask us. The,
asked me to take pictures and then
I say camera coming towards me.
And then that's Michael.
That's after the,
the governance and Michael the
system using, they'll let you f book,
you're an on me again
because then, and then, uh,
then I look in his face and I was like,
what as I do it, I'll put you back.
And then he create, create
kind of a buzz word, a fight,
and we start to shout at each other and
it kind of almost pushed each other.
I'm Jason [inaudible] boys
leave it fortified. Boy,
that is so, but it's, it's
not staged. It's true. Now
I'm like, man, what the hell?
He is doing there,
but then after I realize it go,
it was on TMZ where I come out
right there. Then they kids,
they came through asking me for
another graph. They can, they can.
They kind of get a intimidating,
they were like,
they went back. Then I turned
around, I was like, it's okay.
It's Spanish and all you can
come in and go. They get,
when they went back to their, I read,
I'm like, Oh God, what? It is what it is,
you know? But that was probably the
best promotion of the old fight,
like that particular as an incident,
you know what I mean?
So I hate him and I love him the same way.
Michael just kind of a guidance.
He's,
he's a pro at at boosting the
anticipation for a fight hype.
You want to hate them,
but you kind of love him.
And then the same way for the human
being that he is, you know? No,
he's great to talk and shit
for sure. Yeah. That is a
big thing these days. I mean,
especially after Connor,
Connor Mcgregor has kind of changed the
sport and a lot of ways and that there,
that shit talking is a, it's
a huge factor now. It is,
but sometimes you don't know when is
really when it's not because I'm not,
it's not part of my personality.
And same thing at the Espn in Boston,
same thing.
We do an interview, we go back
and forth, Blah Blah Blah.
I kind of almost insulting each other.
So resource me.
Then, uh, the UFC does everything to
separate us for me, one of each other.
Like I'm like,
I don't know if it's real or not.
I don't even know if he's trying to push
my, I gotta push him back cause I feel,
I felt threatened thing.
So you don't know if it's hype or
myself because I'm not an instigator.
I don't like golf rotation,
but it is what it is.
So I go to the bathroom in between.
Who comes next to the bathroom with us?
It's by code base back then.
Is that Camaro that Paula was in a
bathroom. I'm, we're taking a piss now.
Next to each other. We're
like this. Then I see Michael
Bizarre, like, oh, this shit.
Then the camera at any telecom
area, two to f out is, I get out,
the number camera goes out. They
need, look at me, look at him.
Then he started laughing,
then started laughing.
Then I told him, I said, hey, you
get a range rover? He's like, yeah,
but now he's in the garage.
I'm like, yeah, it's a,
you need to get rid of it because after
a while it does start breaking down is I?
Yeah. You know, it was, I
came game phase two later
on. Do you want to hate that guy
like this? You know what I mean? Oh,
that's hilarious. But I hate him
because when we, we insult each other,
we say real and salt and real things
that we think about each other, but in a,
in a way we have the respect.
Yeah. So it's really,
but so with that relationship that
I have with Bisping was very unique.
I didn't have the same relationship
with Diaz, for example, Diaz.
I didn't know if like if I meet him,
him even industry too,
they may be hates my guts. Like I
don't know what he's going to write.
I don't know if he wanted to fight me
or he might really want to fight you,
but he's not a hype guy.
I think he's,
I think he takes it personal
and I think he, it's, man,
it's a freakin spark man is
more to life than what it is.
It was a are fighting his might now,
man, fighting is not my life, man.
My life is my family. Man is,
is my friend. The people I love.
This is what I do in my life is not
my life. I need, the fighting is over.
It's over. I turned around and do
something else. You know what I mean?
Like is what I do in my life, some
of my life. You know what I mean?